the more recent story is jessica krug
who this funniest one let's see this is
the funniest one
i mean if we're going to measure them on
funny yeah rachel dolezal was the
funniest yeah but now
uh jessica krug if they went out on the
road jessica krug would headline and
rachel dolezal would feature jessica
krug well
well if they went on the road yeah
jessica krug headline rachel doll's all
featured but the opener would be jessica
krug's alter ego jessica lamb
jessica la boom barrera
so jessica krug who's a [ __ ] white
woman born and raised in kansas city
a jewish white woman from the suburbs of
kansas city yeah
she took on the alter ego of jessica
lambumba lana
and posed as a african afro-caribbean
woman
and actually used it to get jobs and was
a tenured professor at george washington
university for like 15 years
teaching studies african-american
studies and
complaining about how white people are
ruining this country
when she in fact was a [ __ ] white
woman ruining this country
i mean it's really great can we play a
little clip yeah
please play that clip talking at the
city council because uh on the zoo
meeting yeah i mean now is this so
uh psychopathy to you she's a sociopath
what it's
it's how can you just love blessings
it's be it's psychopath
it's being a sociopath it's it's uh you
know
not being able to be okay with the
conditions of your life it's wanted to
be a victim it's entitlement
it's insecurity here we go here we go
you think this is mauricio rodriguez
yeah
i'll be honest his comedy videos but
it's not hey i'm jessa bonbalera i'm
here in el barrio
east harlem uh you probably know this
neighborhood
just i just want to make sure the viewer
the listener understands right now our
fans understand that this is a white
woman from kansas city
who has not yet come out publicly and
said she is in fact a weimaran kansas
city
she's still playing this charade and
she's still playing this race card
which i genuinely believe at this point
because of the
things that are happening in our country
she needs to be brought up on federal
charges
there needs to be a charge you cannot do
this now i disagree she got away with
this for like three
four books 13 years she made a whole
career out of it she's a professor at
george washington university
very prestigious university with a very
prestigious job she's been able to
if there should be a rule if you get
away with it for 10 years
yeah you've passed the test fair enough
you've you you've achieved something
fair enough and you become black fair
enough get your card where they say you
know what
good on you you fooled us for 10 years
you win fair enough yeah it's almost
like yeah if you're like cheating on
your wife for like 10 years and you
don't get caught you have another family
after the 10th year it's like you have
to just now
everybody's just got to be okay with it
there's nothing anybody can do
i want there's got to be a statutes of
limitations on
how long you can be canceled if you can
if you got away with something for 10
20 years you can't cancel somebody you
have to tip your hat to them tip your
hands
you say good [ __ ] job jessica love
balera good job we should have to call
her jessica yeah
balera which is the funniest name do you
think she was just sitting there going
like
in her brain do you think she talks like
that to herself and her brain or her
brain sounds more
more like yeah because she's a jewish
girl she's like a jewish girl from long
island from kansas city
so do her thoughts sound like this or in
her own head does she change it and say
listen
these white [ __ ] here are not
yielding their time
to me because they gentrify my
neighborhood and i'm jessica labu
and i won't have any time for these
[ __ ] white devils coming in my
neighborhood because i'm an unrepentant
child of the hood
that's how she does you think she
thought 100 100
do your thoughts sound like this hi hi
christy what are we going to do today
we're going to wake up this morning
we're going to get ourselves a black and
white because we've been good but we're
going to be a little naughty because we
can reward ourselves
for working out with anthony god did
anthony look good this morning
yes
is that how you're doing that but they
come out like i'm christy i'm a guy but
in your brain what is your what is the
voice in your head sound
when i wake up truly when i wake up when
my eyes open when i'm in bed
i'm waking up my body and brain wakes up
i think i'm a woman it's not until my
feet hit the floor
and do i hear the creaks of the floor
and realize how much weight i'm carrying
do i remember i'm a man
yeah yeah yeah because when the feet hit
the floor they're shaped like
a heat high heel yeah so you're still a
woman until you stand up and you carry
all that weight yeah and then i just see
my penis and then one day
do you have body dysmorphia when you
look in the uh what is that gender
dysphoria gender dysmorphia yeah
it must be weird to have the soul of a
woman and then see a
very ma you have a manly head i know
your head looks like it's a helmet yeah
it was almost like if i
my face and i put on a helmet right like
it's like you have a natural helmet you
got a big projecting male brow
right you look like a real guys guy and
then you come out and you just
your soul is like this yeah i'm coming
out of your soul works
yeah working every
you present as a man but your soul is
100 whitney houston whitney houston baby
i come i love it i'm alive yeah no i
it's just what it is yeah i i am
i'm not 100 but i would say 70 percent
sure
that if i make it to 50 the last 50 i
will i will try to go
as a woman now just to feel it if you
banged out jessica la
right and you found out she was jessica
krug
would you get less attracted to her less
attractive
more attractive yeah her as jessica la
boomba with the nose ring i mean she's
going to get the construction boot
she's going she's going to get she's
going to get one off the face
yeah now if you want to know what a
construction boot means just like
picture somebody who's just been
painting all day what their boot looks
like yeah it's a lot of white stuff all
over it
all right so let's let's let's do this
you see her those boomerangs she kind of
looked like a piece yeah
she looked like a pencil but also was
kind of like a kind of piece but here
she here she just looks like a fat
you know like lesbian yeah so here's
here's jessica
burrito who used to be the speaker your
city council sold my [ __ ]
neighborhood to developers and
gentrifiers
so i got a couple of things to say and
when y'all come on and tell me my time
stops
[ __ ] out of here it's been seven hours
not only did i have to listen to these
cops
and not just the cops but to be honest
with them city council members
you close on like you're opposing them
for your sound bites for your social
media
for your re-election campaigns [ __ ] out
of here you've been supporting the cops
in the pandemic nothing
when the mta was strapped and you
supported putting more cops on the mta
[ __ ] out of here we know where you're
coming from and we know what these
little see i could tell it's an accent
i also wanted people couldn't all these
guys
waited four hours she was beloved you
know a lot of it you can get away with
this amount of [ __ ] in that world
because
let's just be honest most of that world
is [ __ ] [ __ ]
i mean you go to study like his or
you're taking a class on [ __ ]
whatever it's all [ __ ] or math and
science and history what happened it's
what it is
this whole like activist version of of
course
it's all [ __ ] you could come in and
say anything it's like this whole
[ __ ] field or culture of
of of liberal arts through the lens of
like [ __ ] victimization comes with a
certain amount of [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] humans are [ __ ] no matter what
color they are
and they're all so great no matter what
color they are
so this [ __ ] is actually more racist
than
anyone who's walking down the street
who's [ __ ] going you know what we got
to get rid of this certain that
whatever the [ __ ] they're saying because
you know what i mean
at least that person you know who they
are yep and you know okay
they're small-minded whereas this is an
actual
[ __ ] vulture she's like a leech she's
saying i'm against gentrification
she is the gentrifier well okay but why
did jessica crew
krug kruge lumboo why did she come out
and say
she got outed by a i was gonna say so
it's not like it was on her own accord
like she had this existential crisis
inside of her
something was about to go down and she
said let me let me eminem it she came
clean and she eminem that right she
eight-miled it
by coming out to try to get ahead of it
and just admit everything because it was
about to come out
she had been found out she was a jewish
woman from
the suburbs of kansas city went to
private school she's been estranged from
her family she even skipped her own
mother's funeral
because she felt like that would expose
her because her mother's wife my
mother's
white she's white so uh it was a latin
student an afro
caribbean latin student who started to
question her
when they started to actually talk about
this prominent
um hispanic writer who uh uh
he uh this cuban uh afro-cuban
writer okay or she didn't know who who
they knew who's a
member of history in these fields or
whatever and it turned out that they
found out in retrospect he was lying
he wasn't afro-cuban so he was lying
to pass in this world of like hey what's
up you know [ __ ] we're trying to the
white devils
wow so then so was student uncover this
student was about to uncover me and she
came clean and meeting
what actually can we read like yeah yeah
that's what happened so the student was
about to catch her so she came out
she said i'm not a culture vulture i'm a
culture leech i'm from a great part of
my adult life i've been living a lie
she's been lying and the best thing is
is like she goes
hard she attacks white people constantly
one of her neighbors as a white woman
always said like this is the problem
with y'all
she's a smart kid she's got a phd from
the university of wisconsin got a phd in
this [ __ ]
i mean let's be honest what the [ __ ] is
sociology
yeah that's true gender studies it's
[ __ ] you got a piece
i'm not calling anyone who's got a phd
in [ __ ] sociology a doctor
we need to stop that yeah let's just
call it something else what can we call
it
you got a phd in [ __ ] so it's a phb
yeah you're a [ __ ] something
something [ __ ] yeah post
what is it post humoral doctorate post
numeral [ __ ] yeah i mean you're
a doctorate but let's you're closer to a
doctorate
than these people who have a doctor
because i have a medical field yeah
because at least you can [ __ ] put
your hands on my balls and tell me if i
got
cancer and i need to ask you again can
we do it after the episode do you really
are you having some problems no no but
you're a guy
here's the thing you're a guy when you
touch another man
you know how to separate and do it
medically yeah because you've touched my
back a few times and i didn't feel weird
right i didn't feel like gay about it
you know how to just put that aside
and handle someone physically medically
yeah here's but cuz make no mistake
after i did that to you i [ __ ] went
home
and i [ __ ] hit my pocket [ __ ] heart
yeah yeah cause you're a doctor you're a
doctor you're a [ __ ] doctor a [ __ ]
doctor
i mean you're a doctorate so oh so this
lady jessica krug jessica
boom banana much like clarence king for
whatever
clarence king decided to do it for love
she decided to do it to be a victim and
to get involved to get ahead in life
i think she should be there should be
there is a crime here though i
understand the 10-year rule which i'm
willing to give you a pass on this but
there should be some crime
here that needs to be kind of brought up
now but no it's the same thing
as like uh the long island medium or
john edward what was his name
john yeah you want to believe the
[ __ ] i mean if you want to believe
it
that's good if you're there i mean it's
like are you gonna put up the long
island medium on charges because she's
pretending to speak to larry
i mean if if yeah if you cuz my mom's
been talking to a dog psychic
trying to get in touch with larry she's
saying he's not there yet i'm gonna pass
out because i got covered too so i'm
extra lightheaded
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild